a horse knows what they're supposed to
do by what your legs are asking the way
you sit in that saddle the way your legs
move the way your calves sight and the
way your feet bump or horse all of those
things are communication I guess you can
say I'm at a disadvantage I can only use
my hands and my voice to communicate
with my horse because I can't move my
legs
[Music]
my name is Amber Lee Snider and I'm a
professional girl resource real racing
is a food event in the world of rodeo
there are three barrels set up in the
arena and you do a cloverleaf pattern
around those barrels and it's all timed
so the fastest time wins real racing
isn't just what I do
my horses and competing a rodeo it's a
part of who I am I started riding at 3
and competing a real racing at the age
of 7 just loved it ever since then I
mean I've done it all through the junior
rodeo days up in the high school college
rodeo and knowledge the professional
level only days before I was going to
buy my pro rodeo permit I was in a
rollover car accident where I was
ejected and broke my back which
paralyzed me from the waist down doctors
told me slim to no chance that I would
be able to walk again it was going to be
impossible to ride that wasn't an option
for me riding was what I was going to do
I didn't care what had happened at a
starting therapy sensation started
coming back in my legs when I got back
on my horses that only got better the
very first time I got back on my horse I
realized that it wasn't going to be the
same
the biggest change is valence I went
through the modifications we build on my
saddle the first rapture on my legs all
these pieces that made it so that I
could ride the horse I have now his name
is lysine aka legs I named in that
because that's what he becomes
every time I get sleeved my wheelchair
my trailer I now had to use my hands and
my voice where my legs were now piece I
couldn't use he's the one that has made
all of those impossible things possible
I mean he's the one that has brought me
back into that arena to be not just a
participant but a competitor to make the
National Finals Rodeo and be a world
champion barrel racer is my biggest goal
I've won over 70 buckles before my
accident but this buckle this is my
first buckle I won since my accident
took me six years to get to win this one
there's been points where I wanted to
quit there's good points where it's been
through hard
it doesn't matter what the odds are it
doesn't matter what people say you're
the only one that gets suicide of you're
capable of
[Music]
you
[Music]